you mentioned that Palestinians invoke
the plight of indigenous people like
Native
Americans what works and doesn't work
about this analogy so I think that
there's a powerful connection between
the Palestinian people and the
indigenous in this land and in other
places um that have been
wronged uh we are living here in the
United States on Stolen lands that is
drenched in the blood of the
natives and that was built upon uh with
the Blood Sweat and labor of enslaved
Africans that were brought from
overseas it's a great evil that we have
to reckon with constantly and so I think
that's the power of solidarity and you
know if you look in Canada and you look
in places like
Australia uh there has been a refocus on
the crimes against the indigenous of
those places I think that what
makes the pal inian plight
um deeply painful and maybe where the
analogy uh even doesn't do
justice is that from the river to the
sea is less than 500 times what the
United States is in terms of land it's
not that big of a piece of land and so
the original lie
was a land without a people for a people
without a land and the problem was that
there were people on that land that were
forcibly removed so I think that the
sheer size right we're talking about a
tiny piece of land and a lot of people
that were uh removed uh forcefully from
their land and that continue to be
brutalized under those miserable
conditions